hello
and welcome to this session on data
science my name is mohan
and today we are going to take a look at
what this
buzz is all about so now let's talk
about the life cycle
of a data science project okay the first
step
is the concept study in this step it
involves
understanding the business problem
asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with
all the stakeholders understand what
kind of data is available
and all that is a part of the first step
so here are a few examples we want to
see
what are the various specifications and
then what is the
end goal what is the budget is there an
example of this kind of a problem that
has been maybe solved earlier
so all this is a part of the concept
study
and another example could be a very
specific one to predict the price of
a 1.35 carat diamond and there may be
relevant information inputs that are
available
and we want to predict the price the
next step
in this process is data preparation
data gathering and data preparation also
known as
data munching or sometimes it is also
known as data manipulation so what
happens here is the
raw data that is available may not be
usable in its current format for various
reasons so that is why
in this step a data scientist would
explore the data
he will take a look at some sample data
maybe
there are millions of records pick a few
thousand records and see how the data is
looking are there any gaps
is the structure appropriate to be fed
into the system
are there some columns which are
probably
not adding value may not be required for
the analysis
very often these are like names of the
customers they will probably not add any
value or much value
from an analysis perspective the
structure of the data maybe the data is
coming from multiple data sources
and the structures may not be matching
what are the other problems
there may be gaps in the data so the
data all the
columns all the cells are not filled if
you're talking about structured data
there are several blank records or blank
columns
so if you use that data directly you'll
get errors or you will get inaccurate
results
so how do you either get rid of the data
or
how do you fill this gaps with something
meaningful
so all that is a part of data munching
or data manipulation so these are some
additional sub topics within that so
data integration is one of them if there
are any conflicts
in the data there may be data may be
redundant data resident redundancy is
another issue
there may be you have let's say data
coming from two different systems
and both of them have customer table for
example customer information
so when you merge them there is a
duplication issue so how do we resolve
that so
that is one data transformation as i
said there will be situations where
data is coming from multiple sources and
then when we
merge them together they may not be
matching so we need to do some
transformations to make sure
everything is similar we may have to do
some
data reduction if the data size is too
big
you may have to come up with ways to
reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
the wrong values or null values or there
are missing values so how do you handle
all of that
a few examples of very specific stuff so
if there are
missing values how do you handle missing
values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value
then you have null value you see the
difference between the two right so in
the missing value there is nothing
blank null value it says null now the
system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a
string or a non-numeric value so how do
we clean
and prepare the data so that our system
can work flawlessly
so there are multiple ways and there is
no
one common way of doing this it can vary
from
project to project it can vary from what
exactly is the problem we are trying to
solve
it can vary from data scientist to data
scientist organization to organizations
so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course
there will be a lot of trial and error
somebody would have tried out something
and it worked and will continue to use
that mechanism so
that's how we need to take care of data
cleaning now
what are the various ways of doing you
know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large
and only a few records have some missing
values
then it is okay to just get rid of those
entire
rows for example so if you have a
million records and out of which
100 records don't have full data so
there are some missing values in about
100 cards so it's absolutely fine
because
it's a small percentage of the data so
you can get rid of the entire records
which are missing values
but that's not a very common situation
very often you will have
multiple or at least a large number of a
data set for example out of million
records you may have
50 000 records which are like having
missing values now
that's a significant amount you cannot
get rid of all those records
your analysis will be inaccurate so
how do you handle such situations so
there are again multiple ways of doing
it one is
you can probably if a particular values
are missing in a particular column
you can probably take the mean value for
that particular column
and fill all the missing values with the
mean value so that
first of all you don't get errors
because of missing values and second
you don't get results that are way off
because these values are completely
different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be
either taking the median value or
depending on
what kind of data we are talking about
so something meaningful we will have put
in there
if we are doing some machine learning
activity
then obviously as a part of data
preparation you
need to split the data into training and
test data set the reason being
if you try to test with a data set which
the system has already seen as a part of
training
then it will tend to give a reasonably
accurate results because it has already
seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the
system so typically you take the entire
data set the input data set and split it
into
two parts and again the ratio can vary
from person to person individual
preferences some people like to split it
into
50 50 some people like it as 63.33 and
33.3 is basically two third and one
third
and some people do it as 80 20 80 for
training and 20 for testing so you split
the data
perform the training with the 80 percent
and then use the remaining 20 for
testing all right
so that is one more data preparation
activity
that needs to be done before you start
analyzing or applying the
data or putting the data through the
model then the next step is
model planning now these models can be
statistical models this could be machine
learning model so you need to decide
what kind of models you're going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regression algorithm
and come up with a regression model so
it could be linear regression
or if you're talking about
classification then you need to
pick up an appropriate classification
algorithm
like logistic regression or decision
tree or svm
and then you need to train that
particular
model so that is the model building or
model planning process
and the cleaned up data has to be fed
into the model
and apart from cleaning you may also
have to in order to determine what kind
of model you will
use you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis
to understand the relationship between
the various variables and
see if the data is appropriate and so on
right so that is the
additional preparatory step that needs
to be done
so a little bit of details about
exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis is
basically to
as the name suggests you're just
exploring you just receive the data and
you're trying to explore and
find out what are the data types and
what is the
is the data clean in each of the columns
what is the maximum minimum value so for
example
there are out of the box functionality
available in
tools like r so if you just ask for a
summary of the table
it will tell you for each column it will
give some details as to what is the mean
value what is the maximum value and so
on and so forth
so this exercise or this exploratory
analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to
during this process you find there are a
lot of missing values you need to take
steps to
fix those you will also get an idea
about what kind of model
to be used and so on and so forth what
are the various techniques
used for exploratory data analysis
typically
these would be visualization techniques
like you use histograms
uh you can use box plots you can use
scatter plots
so these are very quick ways of
identifying
the patterns or a few of the trends of
the data and so on
and then once your data is ready you
you decided on the model what kind of
model what kind of algorithm you're
going to use
if you're trying to do machine learning
you need to
pass your 80 percent the training data
or rather you use that training data to
train your model
and the training process itself is
iterative so
the training process you may have to
perform multiple times
and once the training is done and you
feel
it is giving good accuracy then you move
on to
test so you take the remaining 20 of the
data
remember we split the data into training
and test
so the test data is now used to
check the accuracy or how well our model
is performing
and if there are further issues let's
say and model is still
during testing the accuracy is not good
then you may want to retrain your model
or use a different model so this whole
thing again can be iterative but if the
test process
is passed or if the model passes the
test then it can go into
production and it will be deployed all
right so
what are the various tools that we use
for model planning r is an excellent
tool
in a lot of ways whether you're doing
regular statistical analysis
or machine learning or any of these
activities are in
along with our studio provides a very
powerful environment to
do data analysis including visualization
it has a very good
integrated visualization of plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then
later on to do analysis detailed
analysis and machine learning and so on
and so forth then of course you can
write python
programs python offers a rich library
for performing data analysis
and machine learning and so on matlab is
a very popular
tool as well especially during education
so this is a very easy to learn tool so
matlab is another
tool that can be used and then last but
not least sas
sas is again very powerful it is
a preparatory tool and it has all the
components that are required to perform
very good statistical analysis or
perform data science so
those are the various tools that would
be required for or that
that can be used for model building and
so the next step is model building so we
have done the planning part
we said okay what is the algorithm we
are going to use what kind of model we
are going to use
now we need to actually train this model
or build the model rather
so that it can then be deployed so what
are the various
uh ways or what are the various types of
model building activities
so it could be let's say in this
particular
example that we have taken you want to
find out the price
of 1.35 carat diamond so
this is let's say a linear regression
problem
you have data for various carets of
diamond
and you use that information you pass it
through
a linear regression model or you create
a linear regression model
which can then predict your price for
1.35
carat so this is one example of
model building and then a little bit
details of how
linear regression works so linear
regression is basically coming up with
a relation between an independent
variable
and a dependent variable so it is pretty
much like coming up with
equation of a a straight line which is
the best
fit for the given data so like for
example here y is equal to mx plus c so
y is the dependent variable and x is the
independent variable
we need to determine the values of m and
c for our given data so
that is what the training process
of this model does at the end of the
training process
you have a certain value of m and c and
that is used for predicting the values
of any new data that comes all right so
the way it works is we use the training
and the test data set
to train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using
test data and if it is working fine then
it is
taken to the next level which is put in
production
if not the model has to be retrained if
the accuracy is not good enough
then the model is retrained maybe with
more data or you come up with a newer
model
or algorithm and then repeat that
process so it is an iterative process
once the training is completed training
and test
then this model is deployed and we can
use this particular model
to determine what is the price of 1.35
carat diamond remember that was our
problem statement so now that we have
the best fit
for this given data we have the price of
1.35
carat diamond which is 10 000. so this
is one example of how this whole process
works now how do we build the model
there are multiple ways you can use
python for example
and use libraries like pandas or numpy
to build the model
and implement it this will be available
as a separate tutorial a separate video
in this playlist so
stay tuned for that moving on once we
have the results
the next step is to communicate this
results
to the appropriate stakeholders so
which is basically taking this results
and preparing
like a presentation or a dashboard
and communicating these results to the
concerned people so finishing or getting
the results of the analysis is not the
last step
but you need to as a data scientist take
this results
and present it to the team that has
given you this problem in the first
place
and explain your findings explain the
findings
of this exercise and recommend maybe
what steps they need to take in order to
overcome this problem or solve this
problem so that is the pretty much once
that is
accepted and the last step is to
operationalize
so if everything is fine your data
scientists presentations are
accepted then they put it into practice
and thereby they will be able to improve
or
solve the problem that they stated in
step one
okay so quick summary of the life cycle
you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem
asking the right questions and trying to
see if there is
enough data to solve this problem and
then even maybe gather the data then
data preparation
the raw data needs to be manipulated you
need to do data munching
so that you have the data in a certain
proper format
to be used by the model or our analytics
system and then you need to do the model
planning what kind of a model what
algorithm you will use for a given
problem
and then the model building so the exact
execution of that model
it happens in step four and you
implement and execute
that model and put the data through the
analysis in this step
and then you get the results these
results are then
communicated packaged and presented and
communicated to the stakeholders
and once that is accepted that is
operationalized so that is the final
step
so with that we come to the end of this
session
thank you very much for watching this
video
and if there are any feedback any
comments please
or any questions please put it below and
we will get back to you provide your
contact information on the email so that
we can respond to you
and thank you very much once again and
have a good day bye bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here